you know ever since I was a kid I
remember the exact moment this dawned on
me I'll tell you later in this video but
the concepts of someone being invisible
in a room and you not being alone when
you think you're alone that's that's
always been one of the scariest things
this movie did it right yes yes my stuff
[Music]
The Invisible Man so The Invisible Man
is a take on the story of the Invisible
Man which I believe is pretty
unanimously we can all agree whatever
the dark universe was going to be before
it burned before it even got off the
ground this is better also started out
as an HG Wells novel now we have a new
take on it it starts Elisabeth Moss she
plays a woman who escapes from her very
abusive boyfriend named Adrian Griffin
and that guy commits suicide or does he
as he was a lead pioneer in the field of
optics and she is convinced he is
invisible and he is stalking her and
tormenting her and now we have a pretty
effective thriller by the person who
directed upgrade so I guess I'm just
becoming a fan there are a couple of
moments early on where something
happened that's startling you know like
the phone buzzes mmm on the counter
that's always startling in a horror
movie or a thriller movie you know what
I'm trying to say a movie that it's not
really high-energy and this is one of
the things I liked about this movie I
get to that no it doesn't rely on jump
scares but I was concerned it was going
to at first but this movie actually does
a really good job at just building the
tension and from the get-go when she's
escaping from this guy there's one word
of dialog she lives over in bed and she
goes see if he's awake the next few
minutes is her very quietly and very
slowly creeping around the house trying
to pack her bag so she can quietly leave
before he wakes up which is great
because that sets the tone the first
couple acts of this movie it's not
exactly high-octane it's a slow building
psychological thriller so when you get
that few minutes of her slowly trying to
creep out of the house the audience is
kind of conditioned to it if it had the
contrast of super exciting alright slow
burn now for a couple of acts what it
worked as well so smart also I had a
couple wants in this movie because I saw
that one shot in the trailer where she's
cooking on the stove and clearly you
know dude is right there after the
trailer I was hoping that wasn't just a
one-off shot you know I was hoping there
were a few scenes in this movie that
lent itself to feeling like there's
someone else in the room the camerawork
in this movie really plays up the fact
that this is not a house of three it's a
house of four you just can't see the
fourth person one shot in particular
people were gonna leave the room and
obviously the camera follows him out of
the room but it panned early and then
stopped as if it was panning with
someone else and stopped on someone else
and then everyone else left the room
it's amazing it just gives the Invisible
Man three dimensions this took me back
to Paranormal Activity it's nothing like
Paranormal Activity but it still gave me
that feeling that Paranormal Activity
one
where the fact that you don't see this
thing is actually what makes it scary
it's like someone out there finally
remembered what you can't see is scarier
than what you can because that lets your
imagination build Elizabeth moss was
great too you can't not talk about her
when talking about the Invisible Man and
you're with her because she sells it she
has to sell this movie if she's not
selling it we're not buying it I thought
she was great at portraying a
traumatized person who's growing past it
and then this starts happening and then
there's that other level of hurt that
level of hurt where your friends don't
believe you the movie does a good job at
playing that up to it we'd like to think
if someone was going through that if an
invisible person was stalking a loved
one we'd like to think we'd be like
alright well I got your back where's the
invisible guy you bring him on I'm gonna
lock my guns like I'm Henry Cavill or
something at best you'd be like I
believe that you believe that but people
aren't invisible they do a good job at
you empathizing with the people around
her that start questioning her sanity I
will say in the last act there are a
series of things that happen that I mean
cameras they're out there they're real
they exist security cameras in public
places point is a couple times I was
like please have cameras because I feel
like we can get to the bottom of those
right now with a camera I mean if a
picture is worth a thousand words what
security video were 16,000 to 60,000
words a second depending on the frame
rate either she's crazy or not we can
find out today also there's a part of me
it feels like the movie might have been
a bit too long and it's not pacing whose
nothing about the pacing I would change
if you like the pacing completely works
for this movie everything in terms of
time maybe they could have shaved 10 or
15 minutes but the last act starts to
pick up and starts getting a little more
exciting and I suppose they wanted to
showcase a bit of that but funny enough
my favorite things about this movie are
the first two much slower acts when the
movies messing with her mind messing
with your mind and you're trying to look
around like okay where could I'll bet
you he's right there movie with smart
clever effective well done really what
they pulled off was one of the more
enjoyable and intense psychological
thrillers I'd seen in a while I'll say
the Invisible Man is a great time worth
watching and worth buying on blu-ray go
check it out go see it go watch it enjoy
alright so here it is I told you I was
gonna tell the story I Star Trek The
Next Generation an episode called
identity crisis they're doing this
experiment on this planet it goes wrong
Jordi's trying to figure out what went
wrong in the holodeck and as the
holodeck does it recreates the entire
thing and then Geordi stops and that
that creepy eerie Star Trek The Next
Generation
raishin music starts swelling when
something creepy areas about to be
realized that mm-hmm
and he goes whose shadow is dad and
there is a shadow on the wall that
belongs to nobody then he has the
holodeck show where that person would be
standing it's right there in the middle
of all of it and I remember being a kid
I was like oh my god someone could be
invisible among a crowd of people no one
would know which means someone could be
invisible in my room or my house the
prospect that an invisible person could
just be anywhere that scared the hell
out of me I slept under my covers for
like a month after that that was last
week it's good to see a movie kind of
carry the torch I mean it's not Star
Trek The Next Generation but also the
Invisible Man have you seen it are you
gonna see it what did you think about it
what are you hoping to get out of it you
remember that episode of Star Trek The
Next Generation scared the hell out of
you - dude whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
it stars Elizabeth Mott it stars
Elizabeth Moore this it starts Elisabeth
Moss who escapes from her very abusive
boyfriend in Adrian tooms not tooms it
starts Elisabeth Moss with its tarsal I
can't do this click that little button
to subscribe you by the way it stars
Elisabeth Moss who jump cutting I'm
gonna jump cut that it speak to them it
starts Elisabeth Moss she plays a woman
who escapes from her very abusive
boyfriend and Adrian Griffin oh [ __ ] did
it in one take